la pregunta básica que seguido
escuchamos en nuestras clases de álgebra
es que qué pasaría si nos digan una
ecuación y nos definirán la sección de
una cónica que podríamos graficar con
esto y bien si la ecuación que no ciudad
no tuviera la forma estándar de ser así
simplemente tendríamos que realizar
cosas básicas como lo que hemos mostrado
en vídeos previos para lo cual ya
estamos preparados así que veamos lo que
nos dice la pregunta y lo que podemos
figurar nos con la siguiente ecuación
así que si tenemos 9 x cuadrada + 4 y
cuadrada más 54 x menos 8 james más 49
igual a 0 pero bueno una vez más como
estamos viendo esta ecuación no tiene la
forma estándar entonces que podríamos
saber de esto y una pista rápida nos
dice que tenemos términos cuadráticas
tenemos xy tenemos un término de iu y
ambos están elevados al cuadrado por lo
que nos puede llevar a decir a obtener
una información de que probablemente
sean parábolas
pero también no solo hemos trabajado en
cuanto a parábolas también recordemos o
asumiendo que estamos trabajando con
cónicas también puede ser un círculo una
elipse o una pérgola por eso tenemos una
x cuadrada y un cuadrado ahora una
bonita pista es que si ambos tuvieran el
mismo número estaríamos trabajando en
cuanto a un círculo y si ambos ambos
tienen diferentes números pero con
signos positivos estaríamos hablando de
una pista que probablemente nos diría
que trabajaríamos sobre una elipse o
bien si uno de los términos fuera
positivo y el otro negativo estaríamos
trabajando con una hipérbola y bueno con
todo esto podríamos decir o quizás nos
ayudaría a identificar las cosas más
rápidamente en este nivel pero aún no
nos está dando una forma estandarizada
para poder graficar así que obtengamos
dicha forma entonces de una forma o de
una manera rápida para no repetir
palabras a este nivel sería completando
cuadrados y todo esto nos facilita el
graficar así que la regla para encontrar
la ecuación estándar es realizando los
cuadrados y entonces podemos comenzar
separando
x cuadradas y leyes cuadradas y
agrupando las entonces por acá tenemos 9
x cuadrada más 54 x y pongamos de otro
color las 'íes' con color magenta que se
llama 4 y cuadrada menos 8 g
y luego por acá tenemos el término
independiente que es 49 y todo esto
igual a 0 en realidad es sencillo lo que
haremos al completar los cuadrados y
podemos encontrar en este caso un factor
para ambos números y en este caso sería
el 9 y por acá sería el 4 para los dos
entonces hagamos esto los que
simplemente estamos haciendo es
factorizar para cada uno de los términos
entonces de este lado sería de 9 x x
cuadrada más 9 x 6 de 54 más un último
número que agregaré por acá pero
mientras lo dejaré en blanco luego con
las veces 4 x de cuadrada menos 4 por 2
es 8 entonces a menos dos más otro
tercer número que agregaré pero también
dejar un espacio en blanco más 49 y todo
esto igual a cero y bueno qué es lo que
haremos aquí en dichos espacios aquí
vamos a completar nuestros cuadrados
entonces en realidad estamos buscando un
par de números uno para cada una de las
partes estamos buscando en números para
los cuales tengamos 3
y estos términos en un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto y con esto podamos factorizar
más fácilmente y por supuesto cualquier
número que vayamos agregando aquí irá
multiplicado por nueve así que serán
nueve veces lo agregado y también
tendremos que agregarlo del otro lado
para que estemos completan nuestra
ecuación y nos altere y de este otro
lado estaría multiplicado por cuatro
igual se agrega del lado derecho de la
ecuación para no alterar la entonces si
pusiéramos aquí el 1 habría que agregar
los cuatro veces del otro lado y por acá
si ponemos el 19 veces del otro lado
puesto que 9 pues no es nueve y ya
completando los y sacamos la mitad de 6
es 3 al cuadrado es 9 y entonces 9 por 9
es 81 qué fue lo que agregué de nuestro
lado derecho nada más lo que hice es
sacar la mitad de nuestro término
intermedio luego lo llevamos al cuadrado
y pues se multiplica por el 9 que estaba
afuera ahora la mitad de menos 2 aquí
tenemos el menos 2 de nuestro término
que estaría intermedio es menos 1 al
cuadrado
es uno y por cuatro es cuatro entonces
por este lado de nuestra ecuación cómo
agregamos cuatro le sumamos cuatro del
lado derecho también y acá simplemente
los estamos completando para no dejar
vacía nuestra ecuación y solo para
entender lo que hice aquí es que si es
equivalente si ponemos el 4 por acá
arriba y decimos que simplemente factor
izamos el 4 en el siguiente paso
entonces en esto es lo que se convierte
en esta expresión así que ahora por acá
abajo 9 iría multiplicado por la raíz
del primer término más la raíz del
tercer término que es 3 y todo esto
elevado al cuadrado para tener nuestro
binomio cuadrado perfecto y lo mismo
para nuestro caso de las 10 y por acá
nos falta sumar nuestro término
independiente que lo pondré de otro
color más 49 y todo esto igual a 0 81
más 4 que viene siendo 85 y muy bien
ahora sí ya casi lo tenemos entonces de
este lado tenemos tenemos que es
por x + 3 al cuadrado más 4 x menos 1 al
cuadrado y restando de ambas partes de
nuestra ecuación 49 esto sería igual a
tener 85 menos 50 es 35 entonces 85
menos cuarenta y nueve serían 36 así que
esto lo igualamos a 36 y como ves esto
está tomando cada vez más forma de la
ecuación estándar sin embargo de este
lado no tenemos igualado a uno y estos
dos términos son diferentes por lo tanto
no podemos estar hablando de un círculo
y para igualar nuestra ecuación a uno
será conveniente que todos estos
términos de este lado los dividiremos
entre 36 para poder igualar a 1 entonces
por aquí tenemos que es x + 3 al
cuadrado y 9 sobre 36 es lo mismo que
tiene 1 sobre 4
1 sobre 4 más
1 al cuadrado sobre 4 sobre 36 sería lo
mismo que tener un noveno y ahora si
podemos igualar nuestra ecuación a 1 y
ahora si ya lo tenemos ya encontramos la
forma estándar y podemos decir que
nuestra intuición desde el principio fue
correcta esta es de hecho una elipse y
ahora podemos de hecho graficar la
entonces primero que todo una buena
forma de empezar es preguntándonos dónde
está el centro de dicha elipse y será
con x igual a menos 3 pues sería el
valor que haga a este primer término 0
cuando x vale menos 3 a 0 y para que
sería igual a 1 y este es nuestro centro
así que grafique moss esto y veamos cómo
podemos dibujar nuestra elipse entonces
por aquí tenemos nuestro eje de las xy
nuestro eje de las leyes
y respecto a nuestro centro estaría en
un cuadrante negativo entonces tenemos
por acá menos 3 y de este lado es 1
entonces ese es nuestro centro ahora
veamos qué es lo que pasa en cuanto a
nuestro eje menor que sería para la raíz
de 4 sería 2 respecto a las equis y 2
por este lado ahora respeto las leyes
que en este caso serán nuestro eje mayor
tenemos que la raíz de 9 es 3 entonces
123 para acá arriba por acá nos
encontramos y 123 para acá abajo y esto
representaría nuestro semieje mayor o
nuestro radio mayor para nuestra elipse
en cuanto a las 10 y luego el 12 es el
semieje menor o el radio menor puede ser
más corto y ahora sí estamos listos para
dibujar esta elipse entonces dejarlo
hago vamos a dibujar nuestra elipse y
voy a hacer mi herramienta
pero mi pulso es un poco malo pero se
vería de esta forma y listo
ahora si podemos decir que lo que
hicimos fue tomar esta ecuación un poco
rara y simplemente completamos los
cuadrados con las xy con las leyes y
luego dividimos ambas partes entre este
número para llegar a una forma estándar
y dijimos o esta es la forma estándar de
una elipse pues tenemos estos dos
términos
ambos positivos y empezamos a sumar y
restar términos diferentes pues los
coeficientes de aquí eran diferentes
entonces estamos seguros de que da una
elipse nos vemos en el próximo vídeo